The Armenian Genocide was one of the
most heavily reported topics during
World War I in the United States.
There's an attempt to crush and suppress
the story into oblivion.
We were the beneficiaries of looking at other
projects and other attempts to make a
film about the Armenian Genocide.
The combination of Eric's belief and I could
see it in him that he wanted to get this
movie made and the subject-matter itself
begged the question okay well how do you tell that story.
The universality of these
human stories appeals to people
from all walks of life and from all faiths.
It's a movie that that I knew was
going to resonate forever.
I think as part of the Bruin family it's really
amazing to see the campus rally not just
about the project but around everything
that it touches such as human rights and
intolerance and the treatment of
refugees and the treatment of immigrants
it's an opportunity for us to use the
medium of film and storytelling to
remind people that they can actually be
active participants.
We realize how we  have a responsibility to not
only raise awareness about the Armenian Genocide
but to then try to remind people that
these types of atrocities are occurring
in the world today.
Doing this has become another kind of really
important moment in my life because it
tells me this is why I do this.